ever since I was a child I've been
depressed and my mother used to always
tell me that I stressed out like a grown
man it's always been a problem for me I
let a lot of people get away with things
and take advantage of me do all kinds of
things to where I just let it go because
I don't want to do it the drama and this
is the result of saying you're not going
to take any more I had a disagreement
with somebody I'm not gonna say who they
are or what they do but this person is
very disrespectful name-calling for no
apparent reason and just disrespectful
evil ass lady woman she's evil
disrespectful ass [ __ ] and I finally
had enough and because I finally had
enough and I took action this is a
result you know it could have been a lot
worse but because I chose not to defend
myself
yes it's the female but I didn't get
into a fight with the female it was
someone else he's uh he sucker-punched
me okay long story short I didn't see it
coming and you hit me directly in my
eyeball and that's why it is the way it
is now this is my first black I believe
it or not I've never had that guy before
you know
some people think they can just talk to
people in kind of wait be ending up any
repercussions anything's gonna happen to
them but they're wrong because you can't
talk to everybody any kind of way if
someone - you have to give respect in
order to get it but some people don't
see it that way they just want the
respect and say [ __ ] how do you feel
about anything well I got tired I got
tired of accepting [ __ ] for people
not wanting to hear both sides of
stories and things like that and just
whatever they say that's what it's gonna
be whether they're right or wrong
they're always right and this in
particular person she's just evil her
heart [ __ ] point pumps oil she's
black evil and I don't understand why
you could be the nicest person on earth
come to her with common courtesy and
respect and just be the most wonderful
person she's ever met and she still cuss
you out a song whatever it would never
make sense to me or anybody else for
that matter but it would always make
sense to her when that first came down
here it was a lifestyle that was
exciting to me nobody just you will
judge you because everybody's doing
something and whether or not people know
about it
god knows what everybody's doing welcome
what's in the dark will come to light
and that's the truth because I hit my
addiction as long as I could
starting at 1669 I was trying to doing
the more hard drugs you know I try it I
start smoking Sherm we're now with maybe
14 I started using harder drugs
sixteen years old that's when I made the
worst decision I could ever make it my
life the first time I ever you crack
cocaine the worst decision I could have
ever made
it's taken my family it's taking my jobs
my car it's made me avoid all
responsibility and because of this drug
I chose to distance myself from all my
family because I didn't want them to
judge me and I don't want to see the
disappointment on their faces because
everybody has such high hopes for me if
I would have stayed with my dad my dad
tried so hard not my father I have a
father but he put me here on this earth
I have a dad who's always been there for
me since I was 11 years old
Here I am now 40 years old and he still
there for me as much as he can he don't
approve of the lifestyle that I'm living
now which I do understand because he
tried so hard to got me in the right
path and I still chose to go to the
streets I always felt like I had plenty
of time I got plenty of time to to make
up whatever I lost or whatever it is
that I need to do always thought that I
had plenty of time
all that time is going now anyone by so
fast
seemed like just yesterday I was a
teenager
I was so happy to make it to my 18th
birthday because I always thought I was
gonna die he killed in the streets
because I was gang banging I was really
gang banging I was tripping I'm not
gonna say where from but I was out there
and I did a lot of things to people I
can finally say now I've humbled myself
I don't know how I was to put it I've
become so humble to where I accept
people's [ __ ] because I know if I go
back to my old self what's gonna happen
to them it can also happen to me to the
people out here don't realize that the
same person that they take advantage of
and verbally abused I'm that same person
they can take you off this earth
I can keep taking off this earth too but
I chose a different way I don't gangbang
no more it take a lot of [ __ ] I got it I
got to be very angry to start saying cuz
all that other [ __ ] I grew out of
gangbanging I grew up on that level up
here gangbang won't get you nothin but
life in prison or a Six Feet Under
there's no benefits in gang banging now
one of my daughter's is gang banging she
just turned 21 I can't tell her don't
follow in her father's footsteps I tried
but she won't listen the hood became her
family because I was never there I was
never there because I was too busy doing
drugs and living the life that I wanted
to live my biggest fear is that my
daughter is out there in the streets and
somebody rapes her for it where she gets
killed because she's from one of the
toughest hood that you could be from my
daughter is six old that 60 [ __ ] that's
my daughter to it that's one of the most
ruthless gangs in Los Santos you know
she loves that there's so much and I
understand why because people were
substitute a gang as their family
because they didn't feel the love or
didn't have the support that I found was
supposed to give their their siblings or
the daughter and sons
she felt that connection with with the
neighborhood so I can't be mad at her
I'd be mad at myself because I chose the
streets and I chose my wants and my
needs over my own
most of my kids are grown I have two
younger boys they're both teenagers now
I don't just even if I'm not in my kid's
life I only want one thing but for them
not to do things that I did to not grow
up the way that I did I want them to
think things that I've never seen before
expand their minds you know listen to
different music see that there's another
world out there other than the
neighborhood that you live in and that
was one of my problems I was in there so
long hour I've always been afraid of
change I didn't want to go to another
neighborhood or go to a new school I
wanted to stay within my comfort zone
I've never been out of LA County ever
I've never been to Vegas nothing I have
I haven't seen anything but what they
show me on TV and in the books I haven't
been anywhere because I don't like
change change can be good or it can be
bad sometimes changes put it better if
they had sometimes changed me for the
worse
- my changes was for the worse
I've been to four different colleges
I have a lot of smarts I am educated I
don't have it on paper though because I
wanted to run the streets I could have
been a number of things as far as a
career
I can type 80 words a minute but you
will never see that or you wouldn't
think so
by looking at me I've had jobs but I've
never kept them very long because I was
trying to hang on to my street life and
at the same time take care of my
business and my family I'm what they
call a dysfunctional Adi I can't run the
streets and get high and still take care
of my business
something's got to give but you have you
have functional headaches people who
have been getting high drinking for
years and still pay their bills on time
take care the family and and the family
that will have no idea that this person
is but but did it to anything I'm not
one of them I'm probably one of the most
dysfunctional addicts know that I know
of because I am my worst enemy I know
that I'm going to make bad decisions the
wrong choices and I know this before I
actually make the choice or the decision
and I still end up doing the same [ __ ]
knowing that it's gonna be bad and then
I still go through with it because I
want that that high
I want to be free for the time being
because I have racing thoughts that
never stops I can never get my mind a
break it's always running racing my
stress level is so high because I know
everything that I've lost
the only thing I've gained from downtown
as a bad arm due to a spider bite this
is a [ __ ] spider that did this to my
arm down to hell-bent on the streets and
I let that infection sit in my arm for
three weeks because I didn't want to
leave the streets when I got to the
hospital they said if I would have
stayed outside one more day they were to
come harm off and I didn't realize just
how serious that was I thought that the
end I thought it was just something
that's gonna pass I always let things
heal on its own I never go to hospitals
or see the doctors anything that happens
to me like my eye for instance I let it
hit on his own I see my hand I broke my
own hand because I was mad at somebody
and I punched the wall pretty hard and
it jammed my whole knuckle my hand is
not the same anymore if you could tell
the difference because I told to let it
heal on its own now my hand is
permanently damaged I've already can't
type in words I mean anymore
but I can still type pretty good I can't
do certain things that I used to do to
this a skin graft that I have the spider
laid eggs in my arm and the infection
because I waited too long to go to the
hospital my arm got so big it wasn't me
they
skinned my arm they took skin off of
here whatever they cut off and then they
skin grafted from my leg everybody
thought that I have been in a fire
because the way my arm looks there's for
everybody downtown this is a brown
recluse spider they did this to me so
for those who are out there not
showering and not taking care of
themselves as much as possible this can
happen to you whether it's on your face
ass whatever you're gonna lose something
I know I did because I chose drugs on my
own health I could have lost my right
arm then I have to learn how to live
with one arm and I'm not even
left-handed so that I don't know how
hard it would be to wipe my own ass with
my left hand I've never done it you know
I'm right-handed
downtown has been the downfall of my
existence
I've lost just downtown alone I have
lost so much I love all the trust from
my family just because of the addition
not because of what I might what I've
done or what I might have done but
because they know what addiction can do
to a person especially the addiction
that I have anybody can make a change
you're never too old not too young if
you can walk talking you're still
breathing there's always a way always
but you have to want it in order to do
it you can't just talk about it you got
to put in work and it's not easy I know
for me it's not I've quit doing drugs
first four um different periods of time
but then I always end up coming right
back to it all it takes is one and that
one hit that one shot whatever it is
that you do can ruin your life forever I
have no idea where any of my family
members are I haven't seen my mother
since 2011 I don't know where she is
my grandparents don't know where she is
my uncles nobody has a clue I don't know
where any of my sisters are but my
younger sister that I grow with for my
mother she passed away in 2008 I was in
prison I didn't get you a goodbye to her
and the reason why which the prison is
behind drugs
my sister she used to come down here and
baked and come home then she would cry
and I lie to her and tell her I'm gonna
be there soon and I would never show up
next thing I know I'm in prison and I
call home they say you know sister died
I just wish I could tell her how sorry I
am for the way I treated her I was a
terrible Big Brother I was not even a
big brother to her I always tried to
push her away and keep her away from me
I have no idea why maybe it was jealousy
because her father was in her life and
mine wasn't maybe that was the case I
don't know but I wish I could take it
all back
my last thought of her and her driving
away in the car crying because I
wouldn't leave with her to go home I
felt all that guilt when I got really
and she passed away all the guilt of
treating her bad hit me all at once like
a ton of bricks and Here I am I throw
these years and she begged me to come
home I'm still here and for what more
war stories
at one point in time when I was a
teenager I was one of the best
basketball players in the county that
was one of the best
I mean they were talking like NBA type
stuff but I didn't believe it you know
styles were coming to look at us I was
in a boy's home as its when I was a
teenager and people heard about this
team that we had the good it was great
and I always ask myself what if I would
have just made the right decisions
could I be a retired NBA player by now
oh whatever
could I have been anything other than
what I am today I thought it made the
right choice I would just listen to my
dad my dad's name was Raymond Johnson
great men he's a great man he has a good
heart
he's the only man that's ever been there
for me the way he has and he's still
there even though I'm doing what I'm
doing
he just wants me to do better as
everybody else he wants me to do I want
the same thing too but what is it going
to take for me to give up so say I'm
tired what is it gonna take
I don't want to lose a limb or even
worse to lose my life I don't want to be
one of those that dies down here in some
[ __ ] tent or on a sidewalk or while
I'm sleeping a car jumped the curb and
run me over it happens people die water
asleep get a man over by car from an
intoxicated driver or something like
that how the [ __ ] does a car jump the
curb if you're sober that wouldn't make
sense something's wrong
if you have an addiction or there's
something out there that you'd really
like doing where there's alcohol drugs
sex boot whatever it is don't get
carried away with it not even water you
dick its water it can be bad for you I
had so I learned that too much water is
bad but that too much of anything can be
harmful to the to the human body if you
have a craving for something prey on it
and just don't do it because you're
gonna feel bad once it's all over with
once you sold your your belongings and
you're broken no more drugs you're gonna
feel bad that you sold your [ __ ] to get
it high and you're not even gonna be
high anymore so you're really gonna be
asked out drugs can make you do things
that you never thought you would do
I went to prison
for strong-arm robbery and I rap
somebody behind drugs you know I never
thought I see see a day in prison in my
life as I was growing up I might have
been gang banging and doing whatever it
is that I might have been doing but a
nurse saw myself go to prison because
even though I live my street life I
still kept myself I don't know something
about school weave Northern Lights
school
I do good in it when I put my and when I
when I go through with him when I when I
push through the effort to um it's a
make an accomplishment I haven't
accomplished many things in my life
other than what you see now the only
accomplishment I've ever made was making
some beautiful kids that's the only
thing I have so whenever I die there's
still be a part of me still here a piece
of me
will still be here on earth whether they
my kids know me like me or love me and
if they don't I can understand and I'm
okay with that I understand you know
I'll still be here one way or the other
to my daughters I'm still here I wish I
wish that I never touched this stuff
drugs I mean my mother
I started out smoking weed if she's
taught that weed is a gateway to other
things and I told her you don't know
what you're talking about
I'm not gonna do any other drugs you
know I was already doing other drugs
when she said that as much as I'd say it
my mother was right
she was right she said get your
education when you get older you're
gonna need it she was right I'm educated
but I don't have it on paper I don't
have a high school diploma for different
colleges I never got anything I never
graduated because sooner or later I
choose to go back to the streets I'm
starting to get to the point where I am
starting to feel a little tired they
mostly mentally physically but mostly
mentally it's hard being out here
especially when you let people take
advantage of you and use you and they
take your kindness for weakness and
you're saying your your humbleness they
take they take that [ __ ] for granted not
knowing who that person used to be or
could be never know they'll never know
about me what I was because I refuse to
go back to that I don't like hurting
people I have to be it takes a lot for
me to get pissed off it takes a hell of
a lot I mean but after at some point
everybody has has a line that they draw
they can't take no more so when you
finally respond to some of the [ __ ]
the people will be thrown to you out
here take this some type of way because
you're always the quiet one you always
you know I responding to anything why
does that change because it's got to
change somehow at some point no more
disrespect you got to give respect in
order to get it you know some people
don't understand that they say common
sense everybody has it that's a lie I
suggest you call sense cuz it's not very
common because everybody don't have
common sense or maybe they do have it
they just haven't tapped into that yet
[Music]
my eye is a result of me standing up for
something that I believed I'll say it
again if you have to give respect in
order to get it it's not just one way
this goes both ways
you can't expect to talk [ __ ] to
somebody and expect for them to accept
it we cool with it without it even in a
month inside that she eats me up when I
don't respond and kick somebody's ass or
something like that
or just go back and forth with the word
I don't and I just let it happen it eats
me up inside it builds up and I get mad
at myself because I didn't do or say
anything to that person but I do it
anyway because I know what I'm capable
of there's people out there that I don't
want to see me like this I want them to
remember me that was you know the good
thing is I don't want them to see this
new person who are you you know I want
them to remember me as I was back then
this person if they see now but if they
could see now they wouldn't know what to
think I had it all and I lost it all
just like that all because of my bad
decision-making
everything that happens to me down here
I can't bring nobody but myself because
I chose to be down here the things that
happened to me might not be my fault but
at the end of the day it's all my fault
because I chose this over my family I
chose this over my health let's get it
together I keep telling myself that
every day and I feel the pressure of
being tired of the streets I'm starting
to feel it now before all these years it
wasn't it wasn't only like that but for
some reason I felt different about this
[ __ ] now
the streets are boring everything is
changed out here it's not fun no more
it's [ __ ]
now people snitching on each other
people hating on each other
and just there's no love down here it's
all lies everything has a motive behind
it can't believe nobody trusts him so I
don't get mad no more I get even I don't
know why but I just had the craving to
get even with people or said I said get
even with downtown so I stop getting mad
and to start doing things to people that
they do you mean and they don't like it
when I throw it back at him they don't
like it I was that one person that
always say yes I I don't like saying no
to people I just I don't know why I keep
you from my last or whatever it is is
they asked me for if I can do it I'm
sick of that because at the end I'm
always the one that loses and
I don't know being downtown is very
tiring
you know it's training if you if you
really think back on all this [ __ ] that
you that I've been through all the times
I've been in jail I can't count how many
times I've been in jail I've been in
jail more times than anybody that I can
possibly think of because of downtown
and my continuous use of drugs I am just
I don't know it's time to get it
together
I'm stuck man I don't know it's hard in
case we go hard man
I get hard but I can't be mad at nobody
but myself because I chose this over my
kids over my family my grandparents I
chose this over everything I have no
connection with nobody in my family I
don't know where nobody is my dad is the
only thing I got I love my dad so much
because he never gave up on me
you know I I'm living this life
he's still there no I'm not asking him
or he's giving me money all the time but
he will help me when he feel it that he
needs to but if he thinks I'm just
wasn't [ __ ] I'm asking him to wire
me money or whatever for my addition
whatever he's not gonna help me and I do
understand I understand completely the
disappointment is so great I mean I
really had some things going for myself
when I was younger like I said before
what it takes is one then they can clean
your whole life out take away everything
just like I've seen people come down
here brand new cars nice houses and sit
and they come down here you know I
started out as once or twice a week then
it'll could be every day they're coming
down here now they're in the same car
but now it doesn't have that look
anymore and now it's just I don't know
got a couple dance up maybe a rim is
missing and you're rolling on a doughnut
wheel I see people deteriorate and when
I mean by deteriorate I've seen them
lose
things step-by-step versus a house
didn't I paying original more so they're
sleeping in the car then they end up
losing the car because they got too many
tickets sitting the same parking space
cuz they're sleeping in the car now the
car is full of all their clothes and
belonging
I guess what that's gonna get taken
because somebody's gonna break the
window and take it all now these same
people are out here pushing baskets and
living on the street due to the same
[ __ ] that I did because a bad decision
making this drug or these drugs change
their life forever
it really can
I've said this before but if I could go
back in time and change it I would in a
heartbeat I'd give my right arm any harm
I give whatever along just to go back in
time and change my mistakes I want to be
there for my kids I'm gonna be a father
and be a dad I'm a grandfather and you
know my grandkids they're young so
they're not old enough to understand
what it is that I'm going through but
all my kids they understand my kids are
smart that is so smart
and they still know they daddy they love
me and I'm so ashamed of what I've
become I will not let them see me like
this I refuse to let my kids see me like
this
my older ones they see me a time or two
in this condition
my daughter my 21 year old she came down
here and I didn't even know she was
coming
I hadn't seen her and I don't know how
long and she turned around she says
daddy and I turn around all I heard was
that voice and I turned on it's my
little girl my baby that's the one this
gangbang you know she loves her daddy so
much he loved her daddy
she grew up so hard my daughter grew up
without her parents she didn't find out
who her mother was until she was grown
she knew about me but I was in and out
because I wanted to live my life I was
selfish I said Bennifer her maybe she
wouldn't be where she is now
I mean as far as the gang banging and
all the gang tats and stuff like that my
daughter she's fully with the business
and that hood [ __ ]
she really is but I want her to change
her ways
my daughter has so much smarts she can
do hair she she just she graduated high
school and I give her thanks for that
I'd like to feel like I had something to
do with that because if I wouldn't have
been if I would have been who to say
that you know I really do believe that
things happen for a reason where there's
the smallest things
it's the biggest things everything has a
purpose there he's second every minute
every hour every movement everything
that's going on around us has a purpose
for some reason and only God knows what
it is
who's to say that if I was there for my
daughter that for some reason she went
to graduate high school who knows then
this might sound silly but I feel like
by me not being there or whatever
whatever purpose may be
she graduated but as weird as it sounds
I feel like I might my bad decisions
whatever however you want to call it I
had something to do with that in some
way I don't know but I feel that I want
to talk about my daughter too much I
hope that one day if she sees this baby
your daddy loves you very much and I'm
so proud of you no matter what you
decide to do with your life you get
something I was never able to do you
graduated good girl
I miss you I love all my kids I love all
of you okay
just say no go the other way I know in
life
things happening just try to make the
best decisions that you can for your
future for your kids future so you won't
end up like me
I love you
you
you